today on the Matt Walsh show bombshell
video surfaces seeming to lend support
to the sexual assault allegations
against Joe Biden of course the media is
not treating it like bombshell video
though but we'll talk about that we'll
also talk about the the allegations in
general and what I really want to do is
compare the case against Joe Biden with
respect to the sexual assault
allegations to the case against
Kavanaugh and the interesting thing of
course is that lots of people who were
convinced that Kavanaugh was guilty are
not at all convinced about Joe Biden
does that make a lot of sense we'll
compare and contrast also five headlines
including a police sting operation to
bust a couple of black market
underground hairdressers and in our
daily cancellation we will cancel a CNN
correspondent who wrote a letter to his
newborn son to inform him that the earth
is being destroyed by climate change so
that that is his welcome he's a sort of
birthday present is this letter but it's
actually hilarious the letter is so
we're gonna well I'll read that some of
that to you and that's all coming up I
did want to mention at the top here
though maybe you've heard the reports
suggesting that North Korean dictator
Kim Jong hoon might be dying or is
already dead or is completely alive you
know it's or somewhere in between
I don't know and his sister kim yo-jong
is poised to take over now some on the
Left have trumpeted North Korea's
predetermined decision to unanimously
vote for a woman as supreme leader and
they rightly contrast this move with the
United States which unfortunately has
never been under the rule of a female
despot much to Hillary Clinton's chagrin
Seth Abramson for example tweeted still
processing the possibility that North
Korea could have its first woman leader
before the United States and you might
remember that CNN has been in the kim
yo-jong fan club for a while now since
the Winter Olympics when they would they
publish an article gushing that the
dictator sister was quote stealing the
show at the Winter Olympics and here's
the thing their excitement is well
justified North Korea is a shining
progressive city on a hill put in the
United States to shame in in so many
areas
I think the media is right about this
for one thing North Korea is far more
welcoming to minorities we think about
this
Asians comprise only 5% of our
population
ok they account for nearly a hundred
percent of North Korea's population
that's how dedicated they are to
welcoming minorities into the fold and
here's the fact that you won't hear on
Fox News every single position in the
North Korean government is held by a
non-white person
compare that to the current occupant of
the White House who except for the
non-white people he's hired has never
hired a single non-white person now more
important of course North Korea is a
communist utopia fulfilling Bernie
Sanders vision the country has no
billionaires at all except for the
ruling family of course but other than
that no billionaires no millionaires
doesn't gonna have thousand heirs that's
how committed they are to income
equality or you know more like lack of
income equality
I mean if nobody has an income then you
have em so facto you have income
inequality or income equality I should
say nor does it have in North Korea they
don't have other gratuitous luxuries
such as food electricity and I think the
lack of electricity in particular has
reduced the country's carbon footprint
substantially positioning them as
leaders in the green revolution so I
know that's something that the Alexandro
kaiser Cortes we'd have to admire them
for best of all North Korea has
eradicated bigotry discrimination by
banning Christianity I mean we could
only dream of these kinds of
achievements North Korea is truly
everything we should be and hopefully
everything that we one day will be and
when I look around at America today
especially the last month I see that we
are well on our way and at least for me
you know that fills me with a huge
amount of excitement I know the media's
feels the same way
all right now in other bombshell news
from the weekend a tape surfaced from
Larry King in 1993 in which someone
believed to be the mother
Joe Biden's sex assault accuser Tara
Reid calls in and mentions that her
daughter had quote problems with a
prominent senator well first of all
let's just watch the tape yes hello I'm
wondering what a staffer would to do
besides go to the press in Washington
my daughter has just left there after
working for a prominent senator and
could not get through with her problems
at all the only thing she could have
done was go to the press and she chose
not to do it out of respect for him or
she had a story to tell but out of
respect for the person she worked for
she didn't tell it Larry King has looked
like an 80 year old man for 40 years
that's one take away more importantly
though Tara Reid was asked about this
tape and she said that that is her
mother it sounds like her mother and
that she also said that her mother told
her back in 1993 that she had called
Larry King and Lynn Tara Reed since she
was upset about that at the time which
of course you can imagine I think I
would be too if I told my mother
something like that and then she turns
around and calls a cable news show but
now if going back to what the actual
allegations are if you haven't read
about it or heard about it and if you
rely on the mainstream media for your
news then you probably have not heard
about it at all but read allege that in
1993 when she worked for Joe Biden when
he was a senator she was assaulted by
him he pushed her up against the wall
grabbed her under her skirt won't go
into the graphic details but you can you
know that's that's the the gist of it
assaulted her and then when it was over
told her according to read Biden told
her that he she means nothing to him and
then she was shortly left let go from
from the from her job after that
happened that's the claim and this is
the latest piece of evidence supporting
it now does this prove anything
obviously not we don't even know for
sure who it is on that tape I mean we
should work told that it's her mother we
don't we don't know that she wasn't
obviously she doesn't identify herself
that way we don't know for sure what
senator she's referring to or what
problem she's referring to
but it is circumstantial evidence
supporting Reed's story and I want you
to imagine okay if you hear that tape
and you think that's no big deal
okay well just imagine for a moment
imagine if during the Cavanaugh hearings
okay tape surfaced of Christine Ford's
mom 30 years ago calling into a radio
show or something
and mentioning cryptically that her that
her daughter had some trouble with boys
at a party imagine that imagine how the
media would react to that the media
would and we both know this would treat
that as total vindication of Christine
Ford total condemnation of Brett
Kavanaugh and it would be the biggest
bombshell revelation of the year we all
know that how do you think the media is
reacted to this story well they haven't
really reacted much at all in fact do
you think the media has even asked Joe
Biden about any of this on camera
directly no they haven't
and by this I don't just mean the Larry
King thing I mean that that Biden was
accused a month ago publicly of sexual
assault he has been on TV many times in
the interim rambling incoherently never
once not once has anyone in the media
even asked him about this directly they
they've they've had him they're asking
about a bunch of stuff most of which
we've already heard a million times
about the coronavirus and their response
and Joe and Donald Trump city evil and
doing a terrible job and we've heard all
that meanwhile you've got this sexual
assault allegation hanging out there
completely ignored they don't even ask
him about it yes they have asked his in
order to provide themselves cover
they've asked his campaign about it
they've asked for statements and the
campaign has issued statements but
that's not the same thing at all asking
Biden himself on camera directly is an
entirely different ballgame and they
haven't done that and why haven't they
done it because they know that
hey that's Joe Biden we're talking about
and they know he's liable to say
anything they know his denial probably
will not seem very convincing whether he
did it or not so they're helping him out
they're just doing him a solid by not
bringing it up
Trump's contempt for these people is
again proven entirely justified now do I
think that Biden is actually guilty well
I don't know personally from from my
perspective I tend to be skeptical of
assault claims made publicly decades
after the fact at a politically
opportune moment like this I also think
that as far as the court of public
opinion goes on these things when when
when accusations are made so many years
later and there isn't compelling
evidence proving them then we have to
assume them untrue I think that's the
right way to go for all you know for all
intents and purposes accusation has made
many many years later there's no
evidence the timing is suspect I think
in that case the right thing to do is to
assume it's untrue until until you're
given reason to think otherwise the
other option is to assume the accusation
is true but then we're destroying a
man's reputation based on the word of
one person coming forward years later
and that isn't fair that isn't right of
course you could say that our approach
should be to just sort of take a 50/50
type of view of it and say well maybe he
did maybe you didn't but really saying
that a man is 50/50 a rapist is the same
effectively as saying he is a rapist as
far as his reputation goes it's the same
I mean you you probably wouldn't invite
a known rapist to your house for dinner
with your with your kids and your wife
right well would you invite a man who
you think is 50/50 maybe a rapist
probably not so that's that's exactly
the point that as far as the reputation
goes it's it's kind of the same and
that's why I've been consistent that
without very compelling evidence we
should assume innocence in these
situations is there compelling evidence
against Joe Biden I guess that's up for
each person to decide
but the point here is about the double
standard okay I've been consistent on
these kinds of things maybe you've been
consistent but many people in the media
and on the Left have not been and so
that's the point we'll talk more about
that in just a second but first a word
from red power bikes know especially
when we're all holed up at home and a
lot of the things maybe we like to do
out in public we're not able to do
that's when you really need you need
some other form of recreation and guess
what if you can if you can do it if
we're talking about recreation that
involves going outdoors and being out in
the Sun and the fresh air
that's even better and that's why you
need rad power bikes whether you want a
new way to commute or to get around the
city or out in nature even with the kids
in tow whatever it is you've got to try
rad Power bikes it's a cross between a
traditional bike and a moped but doesn't
require a special driver's license like
a moped would that's the good part you
can go up to 20 miles per hour without
pedaling so you get out and about
without getting all sweaty they're great
for commuting getting out on the trail
hauling groceries transporting kids in
the back or just you know and those are
all the practical things you could do
with it what I think is best is just you
know just cruising just pleasure
pleasure ride unlike other ebikes
they're actually affordable plus to show
appreciation for those that service rad
power bikes is offering $100 off all
ebike purchases for active slash
ex-military first responders teachers
and students do you know someone who
loves being active outdoors then tell
them about rad power bikes rad power
bikes offers flexible financing
financing for as low as 0% APR and right
now as a limited time offer get a free
accessory with the purchase of a bike
that's where I get a free gift of up to
a hundred dollars in value and free
shipping to lower 48 states to give this
special offer text the word bike to
64,000 that's bike to 64,000 text beat I
ke to 64,000 okay
so I think the point here is about the
double standard people on the left and
the media have a very different approach
from the approach that I'm talking about
their approach has been believe all
women which is an insane standard in
absolutely maniacal way of looking at
these things it doesn't make any sense
at all
that's their standard that's what
they've said I don't agree with it but
I'm not then and of course they also all
believed christine ford they went around
saying for months I believe Christine
Ford you know they they they believed a
they took her at her word and so the
point is yes if you value evidence and
you believe in the presumption of
innocence then you're gonna look at this
Biden thing in a certain way and you're
gonna have a healthy skepticism about it
but if you believed Christine Ford then
that means you don't value evidence and
you don't believe in the presumption of
innocence of those accused so as a
matter of consistency you should be
approaching the Biden situation the same
way which means you should believe Tara
Reid if you want to be a person of
integrity and consistency than if you
believe Christine Ford you have to
believe Tara Reid the evidence against
Biden may not be conclusive may not even
be very good but it's way way way better
and way way way more compelling than the
evidence against Kavanagh and that's
mainly because there was no evidence
against Kavanagh whatsoever there is at
least some evidence against Joe Biden
may not be great evidence but there's
some evidence so unless you are a
dishonest disgusting disgraceful
partisan clown hack if you believed Ford
you have to believe Reid there is no
intelligent or consistent argument for
believing forward and and disbelieving
Reid there's plenty of consistent
arguments for disbelieving both of them
let's compare these for a moment
Christine Ford claimed that Kavanagh
tried to rape her 30 years ago at a
party she didn't remember the exact day
month time year didn't remember anything
didn't remember how she got to the party
how she got home and these details
really mattered especially like the
information on how she got home
considering the way she told the story
running out of the house traumatized
weeping the party was the house of the
house she says was miles away from her
home someone would have had a
her up and would that person remember it
assuming he was a parent or something
you think they remember picking up their
daughter which was she was traumatized
and crying at a party maybe we could
talk to them but no she didn't remember
she didn't rember how she got home
conveniently and she told nobody about
it
no one corroborated any aspect of the
story no one could even craw break that
the party happened or that Ford and
Cavanaugh knew each other in fact the
only people who came forward came
forward to say they didn't believe her
her own best friend from high school
came what came out and said she doesn't
believe her also Cavanaugh has no
established history of mistreating women
or acting inappropriately to them the
only other similar stories came out of
the exact same time one from Julia sweat
Nick who was a crazy person along with
Michael avenatti alleging that Cavanaugh
was was the ringleader of a rape gang
you know a roving band of gang rapists
that went around to parties Oh raping
girls and everyone in the town knew it
yet they all still went to these parties
and then there was a woman who said that
Cavanaugh pull his pants down at a party
drunkenly in in college those were the
only stories go over to read in Joe
Biden read remembers the incident
vividly she recounts many of the kinds
of details that Ford could not remember
she told several people about the
incident long before going to the media
and those people have corroborated her
other members of Biden's staff from the
90s say they believed her now they don't
say that they have evidence or anything
but they just say they believe her we
have this tape of Reed's mother
apparently mentioning that something
happened and then also and this is
important to Biden has a known history
of touching women inappropriately does
that make him a rapist no not in and of
itself but when someone has a pattern of
behavior of not respecting personal
boundaries and treating women like
objects which Tara Reid is by far not
the only woman to come forward saying
that they feel that way around Joe Biden
got a known history we've seen it on
tape we don't even need to rely on
anybody's word for that we've seen it
ourselves and then this accusation comes
out it's it lends it some credibility so
those are all lines of evidence
circumstantial but those are lines of
evidence that Christine Ford just didn't
have and once again you can go back and
just kind of imagine if any of these
lines of evidence existed for in the
Capitol situation imagine what the media
and the left would have done with that
they were desperate for anything like
this and none of it existed all right
let's move on to headlines but before we
do a word from legacy box you know it's
it can be very difficult sometimes to we
fear if you're getting into as we as we
get ready for Mother's Day and or if you
have a birthday coming up especially
when shopping for mom can be really
difficult but she'll always love
pictures of you so that's a pretty good
gift I think it also sometimes strikes
me as maybe a egotistical gift to give a
picture of yourself or your family to
but you know parents love it and that's
why you need legacy box legacy box is a
super simple mail and service to have
all of your home movies and pictures
digitally preserved on a thumb drive DVD
or the cloud don't let those priceless
family memories disappear because that's
what happens instead here's an idea
Mother's Day is fast approaching what
are you getting for your mom how about
memories that will never get dusty or
fade away legacy box helps bring new
life to your old media by unlocking
those trapped family members memories
and putting them in a modern digital
format that's very easy to use legatee
legacy box it just makes it easy you
know you're taking all that stuff that
is maybe in a box and it's getting all
dusty and everything and you've
forgotten about it
you put it in a place that's easily
accessible for you for your mother if
you're getting it for a gift and that's
what I would really recommend it for for
a limited time legacy box is running a
50% off Mother's Day special order your
legacy box today to take advantage of
this incredible offer this is one of the
best discounts they've ever offered
legacy box is perfect for you or for
someone you love go to legacy box comm
slash Walsh and save 50% off while
supplies last okay number one heroic
police officers in Texas have thanked
God saved save the public from a pair of
dangerous black-market hairstylists in
fact officers ran a sting operation on
these women who were discovered to be
cutting hair in their own homes which is
illegal now of course so the cops did a
sting operation they went undercover and
I don't mean to laugh because this is
serious business
they went undercover and they busted
these crooks incredible job I don't know
about you but I feel safer I feel just
so much safer knowing that these people
are off the streets especially as a
parent it's good to have these fugitives
behind bars finally I've always warned
my kids like it like every parent of
course you know it's in it you feel like
a broken record at times but I've always
warned my kids about the threat of rogue
hairdressers and manicurist and I've
told my kids know what is it that we
always say and I don't how many times
I've said it myself but if you're
walking down the road and a woman
approaches you with a bottle of nail
polish or hairspray you run in the other
direction as fast as you can and you
scream you are not my hairstylist I
don't know you you are not my
hairstylist so this is just something
it's it's as parents a threat we worry
about and to have the police putting
themselves in harm's way in dealing with
these psychos I think it's just it's
just great so I want to commend them for
that number two speaking of arresting
dangerous people some other fugitives
from justice were apprehended on a beach
in California this weekend
arrested for the crime of sitting in the
sand and looking at the ocean again just
a huge thank you it's a law enforcement
on that one we can't have people going
around sitting in sand looking at water
getting unlicensed unregulated
prohibited suntan's can't have that you
think about it you let people get
haircuts you let them get tans next
thing you know people are looking and
feeling good and you just can't have
that not when there's a virus going
around why can't you have it I have no
idea but you can't
simple as that number three okay I'm
gonna try to switch off sarcasm mode for
a second at least it's hard for me to do
but I'll try a JCPenney it looks like is
getting ready to go bankrupt and this
brings up an important point because
I've seen this this story online and
some of the reaction has been well this
is this isn't because the Carter buyers
JCPenney was going under anyway and
that's true and you could easily point
out that JCPenney was in relatively dire
straits before all this Amazon was
killing department stores way before the
virus ever existed but what we're gonna
see happen what we're already seeing
happening is all of these companies that
were on hard times to begin with are
gonna die this is the nail in the coffin
nail in the coffin for JCPenney it's
gonna be the nail in the coffin for a
lot of stores like that so that's a
whole bunch of companies going under at
once
companies with shall we say pre-existing
conditions are gonna die all the same
time you want to talk about you know not
flattening the curve whereas before you
know you have JCPenney
goes under that's a that's a hit to the
economy because it's a bunch of people
employed are now now we're gonna lose
their jobs but in the past the economy
can absorb that what happens when you've
got all the JC Penney's in the world
going under all at once along with a
bunch of other businesses that we're
doing okay before this but couldn't
survive a month two months three months
without revenue that's what we're gonna
face number four speaking of Joe Biden
as we were before here he is making the
case for himself and his campaign and
together we're just getting started this
moment reminds us that the presidency is
about true leadership having the
forethought to prepare for the worst the
backbone to lead through chaos the
character
to move beyond politics and serve every
American no matter where they live or
what they believe only one candidate in
this election has all three my husband
our next president of the United States
Joe Biden
actually sorry he's not making the case
for himself there because I don't think
he can string together
that many words coherently at this point
but his wife is speaking for him so he's
standing there awkwardly frowning
actually openly frowning while his wife
is talking about him what I liked about
that though that was a relatable moment
because I think people are getting on
Joe Biden's case for this but I think
every man can relate right it's like
when you're out shopping with your life
I mean prior to Corona you're out
shopping with your wife and she runs
into somebody she knows and now you're
standing there as the hours and days go
by while your wife talks and you have
that same expression you're just waiting
for it to be over and then what sounds
like she's finally wrapping up that's
when there's four Joba and that's when
the smile returns to the face so I can
relate to that at least number five and
here's the latest protest people are
freaking out about very worried about
this protest that happened in California
look at the footage
once again you've got people outside in
the Sun in the heat there's there's been
no data to suggest that those people are
at any kind of significant risk for for
spreading or contracting the virus so I
see no problem at all with with what
they were doing it's it's perfectly fine
they're standing up for their rights and
they're doing it in a in a safe and
reasonable way
good for them awesome okay I've been
looking forward to this let's get on to
it this is our daily cancelation I have
to cancel this guy bill where chief
climate correspondent for CNN so he
corresponds about the climate that's his
job important job and but he's cancelled
unfortunately even though I kind of love
this what I'm about to read to you I
kind of love it it's hilarious
unintentionally hilarious and
unintentionally great but it's still
pretty great so bill we're just had a
baby congratulations on that so bill and
he wrote a letter to his newborn son
published on cnn.com the letter is
called to my son born in the time of
coronavirus and climate change and
here's the accompanying photo which is
important context I think you need to
see his photo to understand what we're
about to get into here okay so you know
there's Bill shirtless his baby snuggled
up against his bosom he's got his eyes
closed and his smiling now the thing
about that photo I don't mean to make
too big a deal of it in order to get on
Bill's case here in fact well I'm gonna
spend the next ten minutes getting on
his case but still you know he's guy's
eyes closed and he's you know and he's
smiling with his head tilted back he's I
guess he's trying to capture the
maternal glow coming from radiating from
himself but you think is he had to pose
for that photo he's not actually
sleeping there he's no one sleeps
smiling like that so he had to say I
guess to his wife hey good
get a picture of this I'm gonna pretend
I'm sleeping and smiling serenely and
get a picture I'm gonna put it I need it
for my article okay let's let's so let's
go to the article the letter rather
which I'm sure the child has already
read and appreciated okay it says my
dearest river against all odds you were
conceived in a lighthouse born during a
pandemic and will will taste just enough
of life as we knew it to resent us when
it's gone okay I'm sorry I got to stop
here just for a second first of all the
fact the kid's name is River is perfect
it's exactly what you would expect you
know you were expecting river maybe
Colton or Axl or Jackson or something
you were expecting something in that
realm and you got it so that's great
and then he says against all odds you
were conceived in a lighthouse what does
that mean I mean first of all why were
you having sex in a lighthouse I assumed
bill ware and his wife are not
lighthouse keepers so what it was just
like a tourist thing where you're
touring an old lighthouse and then you
decided to sneak off somewhere and do
the deed and okay if you did that why is
it against all odds though is there
something are you less likely to
conceive in a lighthouse is there some
sort of scientific reason why you're
less likely to conceive in the
lighthouse than anywhere else but I
don't understand that sentence against
all odds you were conceived in a
lighthouse anyway we have to move on or
it's gonna take forever he says back to
the letter I'm sorry I'm sorry we broke
your sea and your sky and we shortened
the wings of the nightingale yeah I'm
sure the kid the kid's gonna be super
pissed at us when he finds out that the
wings of a nightingale are shorter the
first times he's the first time he sees
a nightingale he says I hate dad why are
its wings so short what did you do I'm
sorry that the Great Barrier Reef is no
longer great that we value Amazon more
than the Amazon and at the waterfront
neighborhood where you Birbal in my arms
could be condemned by rising seas before
you're old enough for a mortgage the
scent of your downy crown makes my heart
explode the curl and your tic-tac
fills me with enough love to power New
York City this is a this is a grown man
writing this by the way just to let you
know just to remind you okay
instead the milk in your bottle was
warmed by dirty ancient fuels and as a
result you will learn to walk on a
planet that has never been this hot for
humans we are just now wrestling with
the implications of this but as your pop
the most poignant evidence was seeing
your mother give you your first kiss
through a p100 mask that smelled faintly
of smoke I'm sorry my boy but we were
warned see for decades scientists told
us that if we weren't careful humans
wooden leash an invisible enemy out of
the jungle and into our lungs but that
was a story if you wanted to believe
actually was out of a lab and into our
life anyway
so we kept cutting down jungles and
prairies and mangroves in the last few
the places in the last few places where
the wild things are to pave and plow
develop and devour everything inside and
as you get older this will be hard to
understand but we were under the spell
of Genesis 1:28 to take dominion over
every living thing we had a strange urge
to carve straight lines out of nature's
curves and were under the spell of a
uniquely human force called profit
motive when we finally realized that the
worried scientists were right people got
scared and went searching for potions
and protections they emptied store
shelves even faster than the jungles and
all the invisible enemy masks were gone
just in time for your birth your mom and
I were so scared that I was about to
swallow hard and pay a faceless soulless
internet profiteer $600 for a $0.50 and
95 when I remembered the mask I used to
protect my lungs from a fiery place
called California it might have saved
your mom from the bio virus so I will
keep it next to my hurricane waders
malaria pills and the bulletproof vest
with the patch that reads
press climate corresponding is a risky
business by the way so he needs a
bulletproof vest
bullets are flying all over the place
you know when he's reporting on the
weather I'm sure okay so there it goes I
it's a very long letter it goes on from
there it starts to
it starts to get pretty starts to get
pretty pretty dark and if we do nothing
it will mean the end of predictable
growing seasons flight schedules and
supply chains resource Wars and tens of
millions of climate refugees changing
everything we know about borders
neighbors and strangers and either
scenario will bring about both the
absolute best and worst in human nature
hero first responders innovators and
leaders as well as mendacious grifters
conspiracy theorists and tyrants then he
goes through a bunch of other horrible
stuff mentions Greta Thune Berg at a
certain point then we get finally to the
end and it says the lighthouse keeper is
vigilant and dependable with a reverence
for nature's power and a commitment to
saving lives this is your destiny my
beautiful river the great thing about
stories is that they are always under
revision now go write a happy ending
okay
couple things here first of all
obviously Lincoln climate change - the
virus is gratuitous nonsense
especially when the evidence is pointing
to this being constructed or this this
being a virus constructed probably in
the right way built out of Legos or
something no it's a virus that came out
of a Chinese lab and and also plagues
and diseases have ravaged mankind since
the beginning so there is no reason at
all to think that any of this has
anything to do with the SUV you're
driving second if you ever as a man find
yourself writing a phrase like the curl
of your Tic Tac toes you need to stop
immediately and reassess everything
about your life and third this all
strikes me as maybe a bit much to foist
on a child as soon as they're born you
know saying hey kid welcome to the world
by the way the rainforests are dying the
earth is ravaged we're all gonna drown
and it might've been better if you were
never born anywho great to have you with
us
just relax bill all right that's all I'm
saying turn it down a few notches your
kid was just born what kind of person
looks at their newborn and immediately
starts thinking about polar bears dying
of heatstroke
so take it easy okay that's you're
canceled for your own good so take some
time just relax and everything will be
okay congratulations congratulations are
canceled and I think well we'll leave it
there for now have a great day everybody
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 if you prefer facts over
feelings aren't offended by the brutal
truth and you can still laugh at the
insanity filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the Ben Shapiro show we
will get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there